yeah you know when to welcome to this
video playing Grand Master take me home
who is that no name yeah I hope I have
solved the web Commission now by simply
using my old one I mean I've gotten a
supposedly better one and this is making
all the problems so i'm just going back
to my old one and yeah maybe that helps
so and we have a rural health exchange
line that i'm not a big expert in but
it's what I can't get play in the blitz
games if I get a 45 I felt it's not a
bad choice as it is very safe and i'm
not a huge expert in the white society
of this there should be six really why
would you want to trade this I don't
like place pushing the same here to
Castle long but I might be wrong I might
be wrong this is not a line that i play
with the black pieces i usually play
other knives not f6 i mean in general
why chair does not mind p straight after
the king and porn ending is considered
to be a win for wide even though it is
not in doubt that easy to win sometimes
i tried this with a student and trying
to beat the big beaten engine and the
engine is really putting up some stiff
resistance i can tell you it's not so
easy
so if i go to e3 here takes takes push
up a to b 3 you know it's a trend is
strapped down some black cannot take or
d 1 and a 2 0 adds an interesting yeah
but it doesn't do all that much right
and what am i overlooking a tactic
possible of course i thought i'm just
going to e 1 here and play c3
I am 2d6 at that make sense to the six
if not vitac now on d6 and repairing his
pawn structure which is not very
desirable and yeah wow it's very
difficult to any to do anything with him
don't see a really great great
continuation from me here problem is
also i cannot move this rook away from
the default get me absolutely no
progress I'm sorry and he get that would
I would need to do that to make progress
but he has roped it to
okay yeah now i can at least take
everything here and try to claim
something due to the a file sticking
with the rook really worth considering
interesting he does it does take with a
rule interesting okay okay the one
doesn't do all that much if i take here
and play with a eight i know i have
corrected his pawn structure but i'm
activating the piece the roof oh I
cannot take all that much of that sets
the thing I cannot attack him so easily
here well maybe f5 is doing something am
Bishop at seven look f8
now look at a group t7 and Wonder isn't
let that macho okay like I could to
whoopsie aight here i look c6 could be a
row huh aight still don't do all that
much maybe snow c3 i can take take
everything c3 and d3 or something what
that doesn't work time warning may I sis
quit f is click there check that didn't
work out all that well
pretty badly played and angrily on my
part okay yeah just King before and I
have no come to play nope doesn't do
that okay check check it should be okay
click and it shouldn't lose I don't see
it losing I also could have gone back
but why not why not try to appease to
win it with getting the H porn as well
then okay yeah now we need winning is a
bit fantastic here really
check check check no wrong from square
hesitated and we need to draw anyway
that's not not with the time Jay Jay Jay
twice surface yeah yeah that's how they
play at the end anyway so now that was a
pretty badly played game I think I
shouldn't get into any sort of trouble
and I actually did a little bit at least
ok so here maybe that was a little bit
rude too ambitious we are always trying
something a graph eight years bishop
personal square so he actually blundered
landed himself yeah this I don't know a
little bit surprised that it didn't go
kinky for indisposition somehow okay
okay can you loop check yep we are
talking probably this is about a draw I
don't think yes I can never win then
check I can always check me I know h5
actually no I'm winning okay but I was
winning at the end yeah okay you have
absolutely no time is it doesn't help
okay okay now now I'm kind of interested
in a little bit how this opening was
played we should be six is also just a
mistake
I didn't get all that much maybe I have
to do this differently like double first
or do do not decide later analysis
milady witnesses mistimed and he's
getting things organized him I should
really have an advantage after after
this bad move Bishop t6 I think it's
bearable now maybe maybe I should just
play like rook t2 hoopty one double
hoods and then go from there 95 was
probably the victim a bit untimely yeah
anyway thanks for watching